THE MEETING TO ORDER. WE
ANTICIPATE QUITE A BIT OF
DISCUSSION ON THIS ARE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO START OUT AS A
SUB COMMITTEE BECAUSE THERE'S
JUST AT THE MOMENT THE TWO OF
US HERE BUT I HOPE THAT WE GET.
THE OTHER FOLKS IN SHORTLY.
MMHM. SHE'S HELPED ALL THAT'S
RIGHT THREE OF US HERE. WE ONLY
NEED TWO MORE COMMITMENTS FOR
CHAIR AND IF I MAY ARM JUST A
SECOND- I WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- MISTER OBERNOLTE
AS A NEW MEMBER OF PERMANENTLY
OF THE COMMITTEE I ASKED THE
GLEE TO HAPPEN HE- BECAUSE OF
ITS- VERY PERCEPTIVE OUR
COMMENT UNVEILS. WELL HE WAS A
SUBSTITUTE. ONE INTRODUCED
RACHEL SILVER S. I. L. V. E. R.
AND SILVER AS OUR NEW SCIENCE
FELLOW HARVARD PHD AND ALL
THAT- AND ATMOSPHERIC CHEMISTRY
SO A VERY GOOD MATCH I AND WE
DO A LOT OF CHEMISTRY HERE AND
THERE VERY GLAD TO HAVE HER
EXPERTISE. HARM LITERATURE. USE
UP SIR WHAT ELSE- SIX MINUTES
PER SIDE ARE DIVIDED UP HOWEVER
YOU WANT TO DO IT AND WE'RE
HEARING JUST THE ONE THEY'LL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RARE SU CHI
WITH THAT JOINT AUTHORS BUFFY
WAKES UP TO MARY SUE CHEAP
PLEASE BEGIN ACTUALLY I WANTED
TO ASK FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
BECAUSE THE BUCKS NATURE. AND
BE IS THAT MAP THAT HAD THE
BILL OR HERE YEAH I WANTED TO
ASK YOUR INDULGENCE OF PERHAPS
A FEW A FEW MORE. FOR THEM TO.
CASE MISTER ARAMBULA HAS COME
IN AN HOUR AND I. GINA GARCIA
WITH THE ARM DISCUSSIONS WE'VE
HAD ARE PRETTY WELL BRIEFED
AND- IF THEY GET HERE ON TIME
LAST QUESTIONS AND IF THEY
DON'T THEY WON'T. THE I DON'T
WANT TO ENCOURAGE- PEOPLE BEING
LATE SO WE HAVE ONE TWO THREE
FOUR WITH ONE MORE WILL HAVE A
QUORUM SO PROCEED ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM
HERE TO PRESENT AB FOUR NINE
FIVE THE TOXIC FREE COSMETICS
AT. WHAT THE FIRST. HARD
WORKING STAFF- FOR JUST A
SECOND WE JUST ARRIVED AT A
QUORUM ALL RIGHT EVEN BETTER
EVEN BETTER ALL RIGHT- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR. JUST ALL THE TO ESTABLISH
CORN QUIRK HERE ARE CARE
MELENDEZ I AM GLAD ARAMBULA
PRESENT OUR QUE HAN ARE CAN
HEAR CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN
MATHIS WHAT I TO JETER NOT TWO
G. HERE OBERNOLTE. WE HAVE FIVE
MEMBERS WE HAVE A QUORUM. I
THINK WE JUST NUMBER TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE THAT HAS ALSO ON AT
THE SAME TIME. HE HAS THREE
COMMITTEE AT THE SAME TIME
SOMEBODY MADE A MISTAKE IN
THEIR SCHEDULING. BUT WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM SO PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU. SO I- WANTED TO
THANK YOUR STAFF FOR ALL OF
THE- HARD WORK THAT THEY PUT
INTO THIS BILL SINCE OUR FIRST
PRESENTATION LAST APRIL. YOU
HAVE PROPOSED COMMITTEE OF ANTS
AND I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT THOSE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- AND AGAIN
THANK THE STAFF FOR- DRAFTING
THOSE AMENDMENTS I WANT TO
THANK THE INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT TO. MANY OF
WHOM I HAVE HAD TO. OPPORTUNITY
INTEL'S SERVE THEIR TIME TO
TALK THROUGH THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL AND I BELIEVE
THAT- WE HAVE HEARD THEIR
CONCERNS LOUD AND CLEAR AS
WELL- THE CONCERNS OF THE
COLDER THE COSMETICS
MANUFACTURERS THE OPPOSITION
THAT WE HAVE- MET WITH AND- AND
DISCUSSED. THEIR CONCERNS SINCE
LAST APRIL WE'VE HEARD THESE
CONCERNS LOUD AND CLEAR I
WANTED TO MAKE MY COMMITMENT
CLEAR THAT TO THAT. WE ARE I AM
COMMITTED ARE FOR OMITTED. TO
ALIGN THIS BILL WITH THE
STANDARDS- AS IT RELATES TO
COST A TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
COSMETICS BUT TO ALIGN THEM
WITH EUROPEAN UNION STANDARDS-
THAT IS- THE CLEAR MESSAGE WE
HEARD NOT ONLY FROM MEMBERS HAD
EXPRESSED CONCERNS BUT ALSO
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT. THE
KARAMAT- PRODUCTS- COUNCIL THEY
ARE CLEARLY INDICATED THAT THEY
WANTED A GLOBAL STANDARD AND SO
IT IS OUR INTENT AND COMMIT.
WORK ORDER THOSE. WILL
STANDARDS AS IT RELATES TO THE
REGULATIONS OF TOXIC CHEMICALS
IN COSMETICS. THIS BILL AS YOU
KNOW WE WILL BAND COSMETICS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CONTAIN
THIRTEEN TOXIC CHEMICALS WELL
KNOWN AND WELL ESTABLISHED BY
THE SCIENCE TO CAUSE CANCER
REPRODUCTIVE HARM OR HORMONE
DISRUPTION. THESE TOXIC
CHEMICALS ARE WELL KNOWN TO ALL
OF US THEY INCLUDE CHEMICALS
SUCH AS LEAD MERCURY ASBESTOS
FORM OUT HIDE AND OTHERS. THESE
TOXIC CHEMICALS FACTORS SO WELL
KNOWN THAT MOST PEOPLE'S
REACTION WHEN THEY FIRST HEAR
ABOUT THIS BILL IS AREN'T THESE
TOXIC CHEMICALS ARE READY AND-
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT
DISCOVERIES OF COSMETIC
PRODUCTS ON STORE SHELVES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HIGHLIGHT THE FAILURE
OF EXISTING LAWS AND
REGULATIONS TO ADEQUATELY
PROTECT CONSUMERS. AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN- WHAT WAS IN FACT
EXPRESSED AS WITH THE ONE IN
SALT FUNDS COSMETICS PRODUCTS
BEING SOLD IN POP. RETAIL
CHAINS CLAIRE IS AND JUST. TO
CHANGE THAT I AM VERY FAMILIAR
WITH AS A FATHER OF A TEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER. THESE SEARCHES
ARE TARGETING THEIR PRODUCTS
FOR GIRLS TEENS AND TWEENS
PRODUCTS LIKE POWDER MAKEUP
CONTAINING ASBESTOS WE ALSO
KNOW OF THE- HI THE. PUBLICIZED
AND WELL DOCUMENTED CASES OF
OTHER PRODUCTS LIKE JOHNSON AND
JOHNSON BABY POWDER THAT HAS
BEEN FOUND TO CONTAIN ASBESTOS
WE HAVE ALSO HAD INCIDENTS OF
FACIAL CREAMS CONTAINING
MERCURY AT OF INDUCED- COMMAS
AMONG CONSUMERS- AND CALIFORNIA
EN EL THAT HAVE APPLIED THESE.
COSMETICS TO THEIR SKIN.
INTENDING FORMALDEHYDE WHICH
HAS A RECENT STUDY HAS BEEN
TIED TO A HIGHER RISK OF BREAST
CANCER ESPECIALLY AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN. SO THE SCIENCE
IS CLEAR ON THE HARMFUL NATURE
OF THESE CHEMICALS THESE
COSMETICS CONTAINING THESE
THIRTEEN CHEMICALS ARE A READY
BANNED IN THE EUROPEAN UNION.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
WITH THIS BILL IS FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS TO HAVE
THE SAME RIGHT THE RIGHT TO THE
SAME PROTECT. THE STAINED TOXIC
FREE COSMETICS AS THOSE ARE
READY BEINGS IN EUROPE AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD WITH
SIMILAR CONSUMER PROTECTION. I
AM UP TO TEAM UP ON THIS EFFORT
TO. NINETY FIVE WITH THE OUR
JOINT AUTHORED ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BUFFY WORKS IN A LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO MS WICKS THANK YOU.
NUMBER NOW KEEP MY REMARKS
SHORT AND WE DON'T ATTEND. BUT
YOU KNOW I COME HERE IS A
LEGISLATOR BUT ALSO SOME I
COVERS. AS YOU THE STATE STARTS
OF SAID WOMEN IS ON AVERAGE
SIXTEEN PRODUCTS TODAY- I WASH
MY DAUGHTER'S HAIR WITH YOU
KNOW CHILDREN'S SHAMPOO- I
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE A
SCIENTIST AT THE SUPERMARKET TO
READ THE LABELS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT I'M STATE. I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON THE GOVERNMENT
TO PROTECT OUR CITIZENS FROM
HARMFUL COME UP WITH THAT IN
MANY OTHER SICK PATIENTS OFTEN
THIS PROCESS AS WE UNDER AN ACT
OF A SCIENTIFIC BACK ON TO- IN
ORDER TO THAT ROLE MINUTE AND
CLEARLY. ALL RIGHT SO ON THE
WITNESSES HAVE YOU AGREED HOW
MUCH OF THE SIX MINUTES EACH
WILL TAKE. ALL RIGHT OUT. DO I
NEED TO TIME YOU AND I CAN TIME
YOU INDIVIDUALLY IF YOU WILL
TELL ME HOW MUCH TIME YOU THINK
YOU'RE GONNA TAKE. IT SHOULD BE
A MINUTE. MINUTE THIRTY GOT IT
OKAY ANYONE ELSE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
FEW WHACKS MANY MISTER BASIC
PLAN AND I AM THE POLICY
DIRECTOR BLOCKING FELIZ AS THE
WHITE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THE CORNERSTONE OF
OUR WORK IS TO HELP. TO CREATE
A WORLD THAT'S BUT FOR BLACK
MOMMAS THE BABIES THE LARGER
COMMITTEE. BECAUSE YOU'RE SHORT
ON TIME I'M GOING TO CONSTRUED
TO THE POINT MANY BEAUTY
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS SUCH AS LEAD MERCURY
FROM I HAD SHOW UP AN
ECONOMICALLY FRIENDLY STORES
PREYED ON FAMILIES WHO ARE
TRYING TO MAKE ENDS MEET. THE
WAY TOO OFTEN LOW CON THEY CAN
MEET THE COLOR THE BRIDGE
ACTION ON ISSUES WE PART. THE
FACT IS THE BLACK WOMEN ARE THE
MOST DIE FROM BREAST CANCER
WE'RE MORE LIKELY TO GIVE LOW-
BIRTH LOW BIRTH BABIES IN VERY
LOW BIRTH AB AND THE RISE IN
ABOUT INFERTILITY ALL IT.
ISSUES AND DIRECT THE CHEMICALS
BEING BE ACTED THIS BILL. EVERY
RELEASED. IT SHOULD DOUBLE.
PERCENT HIGHER RISK OF GETTING
BREAST CANCER. THIS CALL IT
WOULD USE A CHEMICAL STREET-
SOMETHING OUT A THREE OUT OF
FOUR BLACK WOMEN HAVE YOU. EVEN
WE ACTIVELY TRY TO PICK SAFER
PRODUCTS WITH SAFE INGREDIENTS
IT IS. BECAUSE OF THE SIMPLE
ADVERTISING NOW ALL OF THE
INGREDIENTS ARE ON THE LABEL
ARE NOT HAVING A GRADUATE
DEGREE IN CHEMISTRY. YES
CALIFORNIA'S HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TAKE THE BURDEN
OUR FAMILIES WHO ARE TAKING ALL
OF THE ARREST AND NONE OF THE
REWARD FOR. BOTH OF THESE
CHEMICALS AND PUTTING IT BACK
ON THE COMPANIES. NO CAN MAKE
PC PRODUCTS WITHOUT PUTTING
THEIR KIDS AT HEART. THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH AND THAT WAS A
MINUTE THIRTY SECOND I HAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS POLLY MARSHALL
AND I'M A BREAST CANCER
SURVIVOR AFTER MY DIAGNOSIS AT
AGE FIFTY TWO I HAD THREE
SURGERIES THREE MONTHS OF
CHEMOTHERAPY AND FIVE WEEKS AND
DAILY RADIATION TREATMENTS. I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU WHY A BEFORE
NINETY FIVE IS SO TERRIBLY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND TO OTHER
SURVIVORS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
ONE OUT OF EVERY EIGHT WOMEN IN
THE UNITED STATES WILL BE
DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST CANCER IN
HER LIFETIME. AND FIFTY
THOUSAND WOMEN WILL DIE FROM
THIS DISEASE EVERY YEAR. IN THE
UNITED STATES ALONG. TEN OUT OF
THE THIRTEEN CHEMICALS THAT
WOULD BE BANNED BY A BEFORE
NINETY FIVE FROM BEAUTY AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS IN OUR
STATE ARE DIRECTLY LINKED TO
BREAST CANCER. PASSING A BEFORE
NINETY FIVE WILL REMOVE ONE
MAJOR SOURCE OF WOMEN'S ONGOING
EXPOSURE TO SOME OF THE MOST
TOXIC SUBSTANCES IN ON EARTH.
THIS IS NOT A HYPOTHETICAL
ISSUE WOMEN LIKE ME LIVING WITH
BREAST CANCER LIVE IN DAILY
FEAR OF REOCCURRENCE OF THIS
DEVASTATING DISEASE. COMPANY IT
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE TO USE CHEMICALS WITH
KNOWN LINKS TO BREAST CANCER IN
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN THEY ARE SELLING. EXACT
WITHOUT THESE CANCER CAUSING
CHEMICALS. AB FOR NINETY FIVE
WOULD PUT AN END TO THIS DOUBLE
STANDARD. PLEASE PROTECT ME AND
OTHER BREAST CANCER SURVIVORS.
PLEASE PROTECT OUR CHILDREN.
PLEASE VOTE YES TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- THAT THREE AND A HALF
MINUTES ALTOGETHER SO MEN AND A
HALF FOR THE LAST TWO SPEAKERS
OUR THREE SPEAKERS. YOUR TAKEN
MY SPOT SHE'S ME TWO AND A HALF
MINUTES FOR THE LAST. SPEAKER
TO HAPPEN GET OKAY I'LL BE VERY
BRIEF- MY NAME IS SUCH A SERVER
IN A SENIOR SCIENTIST WITH THE
WGA HOLD THE PHD ENVIRONMENTAL
CHEMISTRY VIA MIDDLE WORKING
GROUP. GO AHEAD THE LOCALS
PROHIBITED BY THIS BILL BECAUSE
SIGNIFICAN ARM TO HELP- SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM ASBESTOS IS
A WELL KNOWN CARCINOGEN THERE'S
NO SAFE LEVEL OF EXPOSURE TO
ANY TYPE OF SPECIFIED-
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE.
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
IT DOESN'T RESURGENT POTENT
POTENT GEN- IN HER TREATMENTS
IT HAS BEEN LINKED TO HAIR LOSS
RASHES BLISTERS AND LOSS OF
TASTE AND SMELL MERCURY CERTAIN
BARELY HARMS THE NERVOUS SYSTEM
AND CAN AFFECT THE DEVELOPING
CHILD DURING PREGNANCY. IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN
SIXTY POISONINGS AND- FOR NHà
RELATED TO THE USE OF SKIN
LIGHTENING CREAMS CONTAINING
MERCURY. BALLOTS ARE POTENT
ALLERGENS AND CONSTRUCTORS AND
CAN HARM REPRODUCTIVE SYSTEMS
AND AFFECT THE DEVELOPMENT
DURING PREGNANCY. AND THE CDC
HAS DETECTED- DIE BEAUTIFUL AT
VALLEY IN 96% OF PEOPLE SAMPLED
SHOWING WIDESPREAD. AND
CONTINUOUS- THE PUBLIC HEALTH
IS CURRENTLY JEOPARDIZED BY THE
LACK OF CONSTRAINTS ON THE
CHEMICALS PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS. IN THE US ARE THE
BANDITS COME IN THE WE ARE BUT
YOU DO THIS. YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BONNIE
GANG AND THE DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCACY OF UTICA. COSMETICS
COMPANY WITH A MISSION TO GET
THE FOR PRODUCTS INTO THE HANDS
OF EVERYONE. BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S A CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE PRODUCT. THEIR BODY YOUR
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT DOES
LICENSE THEY WON A COMPANY HAS
FORMULATED WITHOUT OVER
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED INGREDIENTS
INCLUDING THE THIRTEEN
INGREDIENTS INCLUDED- FOR
INCLUDED BAND RESTRICTED IN
THIS BILL. WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SAFE INGREDIENTS THAT
PERFORM JUST AS WELL AS THESE
INGREDIENTS IN THE SPELL AND
ARE MORE COST EFFECTIVE AS WELL.
THE GROWTH OF OUR COMPANY AND
OTHERS LIKE US DEMONSTRATE THAT
IT IS POSSIBLE AND PROFITABLE
TO FORMULATE WITHOUT THESE
INGREDIENTS AND WE ASK THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. THANK YOU. ACT ALL RIGHT.
MY NAME'S LARA THE HEN I'M WITH
CALPERS AND WE'RE AT CᄑC ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS FOR THIS
BILL AND THAT REALLY HAVE A
CAME ABOUT BECAUSE- WE AT
BABOONS- IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REALLY HIGH LEVELS OF ASBESTOS
IT AIRS MAKEUP PRODUCTS
MARKETED TO YOUNG WOMEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY I'M EVEN WHEN WE
BROUGHT THIS TO THE ATTENTION
OF CLAIRE'S INTO THE FTA THEY
WERE UNABLE TO DO MUCH ABOUT IT
AND THE FDA SAID THEY LOOKED
THE AUTHORITY TO PROTECT.
IMMERSED IN THIS AREA. AND THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO. MANDATORY
THANK OUR PANEL. AND THAT
REALLY EXPOSES WHAT WE NEED TO
THIS SPELL WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION NOW TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS- SO THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO MORE- HIGH LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE TO DEPRESS CHEMICALS.
LIKE LEAD AND STATE
PERSPECTIVES IN FACE POWDERS-
AND YOU KNOW CANCER CAUSING
INFERTILITY CAUSING FROM ALL
THE HATE AND OTHER CHEMICALS IN
HAIR PRODUCTS. AND SO WE
BANKING INFO THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT COM BEFORE I CALL UP THE
OUR MISSION I JUST LIKE TO SAY.
WELL FOLKS ARE HERE THAT THE
AUTHOR AND I HAVE PLEDGED. THAT
WE WANT TO HAVE ALL. THAT YOU
THINK THAT CAN BE SOLD IN THE
TWENTY EIGHT T. U. COUNTRIES
CAN BE SOLD IN CAL OR NHà. THE
REAL NICE THAT THAT MAY READ.
MORE WORK ON THE BILL AND
THAT'S FINE BUT- YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ALMOST YEAR ON THIS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET OUT
A BILL. PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE WORKING WITH IT'S NOT
JUST AN IDEA SOMEWHERE SO I I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN DO THAT- SO
LET ME CALL UP THE OPPOSITION
IF YOU FIVE CAN MOVE- AND THEN
CALL YOU UP LATER TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS PARTICULARLY. OF
CALPERS AND. I'M SORRY EDITION
OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LEON TRITON
REPRESENTING BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS AND
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA URGING YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
MANDATORY THAT I AM THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF BREAST
CANCER FOR TIME AND THE
DAUGHTER OF A BREAST CANCER
SURVIVOR AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE TO.
GET ME TO USE FOR IT THE
FOLLOWING- THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS HAN SCARE CUTS ON
SKIN CARE COSMETICS INNER SENSE
ORGANIC BEAUTY JUST THE GOODS
ASSIA. AND Z. NATURALS. LAUREN
COMMISSARY CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL NOT ALL
SELECT REGISTERS SUPPORT FOR.
ALASKA COMMUNITY ACTION ON
TOXICS BREAST CANCER ACTION
BREAST CANCER OVER TIME IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY. HELLO MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH STEINBACH I AM A
SECOND YEAR POLITICAL SCIENCE
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND ON
BEHALF OF CALPERS STUDENTS
STATE WIDE WE WOULD LIKE TO-
SUPPORT TO COME OUT IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOR NINETY FIVE AND WE
ALSO HAVE GAINED BE TOOLS FROM.
GROUPS SUCH AS CREDO BEAUTY
EARTH MAMA ORGANICS EAGLE PLUM
EIGHTY TWO DEGREES DESIGN
STUDIO AND PRODUCTS THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME IS
CLAUDIA T. WITH HELP HERC- I'D
LIKE EXPRESSED STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- ON FOR MYSELF AS
WELL AS THE FOLLOWING
COMPANIES. 101% PURE BADGER
BALM. THE LAYS THE ORGANIC AND
CALIFORNIA BABY THANK YOU. IN
BERMAN CALIFORNIA DAN JACOBSON
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. HI AM
CATHERINE PORTER FROM
CALIFORNIA HELPING ELSE LONG
COLLABORATIVE AND ALSO SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
URGING A YES VOTE ON THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANDREA EVAN TURNER WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION AFTER WE USE THESE
PRODUCTS WE RINSE THEM DOWN THE
DRAIN AND THE BECOME EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS SO THAT'S WHY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU. DID
YOU GET YOURS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. MY
PERSONAL COULD ALSO BE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL NATIONAL STORESHIP
ACTION COUNCIL AND CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO WE
APOLOGIZE FOR OUR LATE
SUBMISSION THE LETTER BUT WERE
IN SUPPORT AS WELL. IT WITH
THEM BERMAN WORKING GROUP TO
HEAR TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FROM
THESE FIVE BUSINESSES SEVENTH
GENERATION SKIN AL SPROUT SAN
FRANCISCO SUSTAINABLE
SURROUNDINGS AND THE HOLISTIC
HEALTH COMPANY THANK YOU. RENTS
SPENCER WITH AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYN THIS DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS JANET
MIDDLEMAN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS WERE ONE OF A THE BILL
SPONSORS AND WERE STANDING HERE
IN PROUD SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU JIM WINBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT NOW
pOPPOSITION AND YOU WILL HAVE
SIX AND A HALF MINUTES BECAUSE
THE OTHER GROUP JUST WENT OVER
THIRTY SECONDS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MANUALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL I WANT TO
FIRST START OFF BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMITTEE THE CHAIR. THE
MEMBERS OF THE STM COMMITTEE
AND THE AUTHORS- WE THANK YOU
GUYS FOR ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AND I THINK THAT IT'S SAFE TO
SAY THAT. BASED ON THE CHAIRS
MEN'S SIDE OF THE WORLD PRODUCT
WILL FULLY AND STRICTLY ALIGN
US WITH THE E. U. GIVES US A
LOT OF. EFFORT BUT I DO STAND
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE TODAY
A AND I WANNA THROUGH THE REED
IS WHAT WE ARE OPPOSED. AND WHY
AREN'T OPPOSE- I ONE OF WITH
WHY WE AREN'T OPPOSED AND WE
AREN'T OPPOSED BECAUSE ANY OF
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES WANT YOU
AND- ONLY. YOU HAVE THE-
CHANCE. IT AND EIGHT. FIVE. OUR
OPPOSITION TO PEACE MAIL
CHEMICAL BANDS- IN THE
MISGUIDED APPROACH OF HAVING
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE PLACE
TO BAN CHEMICALS ON A ONE ONE
BY ONE BASIS WITHOUT. RISK
ASSESSMENTS ARE WITHOUT
SCIENCE. AND IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NEEDS HAS MANY OF YOU HAVE
HEARD SINCE WE'VE MET WITH ALL
OF YOU GUYS- THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZE THAT AND CREATED THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE SUPPORTERS
OF THIS. ONE GREEN CHEMISTRY TO
WORK BETTER. WE DO TOO AND I
THINK THEY'RE AFTER IT'S UNDER
WAY TO MAKE THAT PROCESS.
BETTER SIDE STATE OUR SUPPORT
FOR HAVING THAT. PLUS BETTER-
YOU HEARD THE SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL TODAY ALSO TALK ABOUT YOU
PRODUCTS AND HOW- HOW WE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AS A YOU AND WE
AGREE BUT THE BILL THAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU FALLS SHORT.
AND AT THIS POINT- I WOULD LIKE
TO HAND THIS OVER TO JAY ANSEL
WHO IS A SCIENTIST FROM THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNSEL
TO RUN THROUGH. THOSE
COMPONENTS. SO CHAIRMAN WORK
BETTER MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY-
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY TOXIC MATERIALS A GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M JAN SELVES
PRESIDENT OF COSMETIC PROGRAMS
AT THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL. PIECE PC IS THE
LEADING NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
SIX HUNDRED COMPANIES INCLUDING.
ONE HUNDRED THAT EITHER CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME OR HAVE A
PRESENCE HERE. WE CANNOT BOARD
CERTIFIED TALKS JUST. THIRD BY
THE UNITED ZERO BY ALL BIOLOGY
AS A EUROPEAN REGISTER
TOXICOLOGIST AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY FIVE
WHILE THE STATED INTENT IS TO A
LINE CALIFORNIA WITH CURRENT
EUROPEAN COSMETIC REGULATIONS
AS DRAFTED AB FORTY FIVE FAILS
TO DO SO. THE CPC IS OWES TO AB
FOUR NINETY FIVE FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS. AB FOUR NINE
FIVE SECTION E. PER PERMITTING
THE PRESENCE OF TRACE MATERIALS
SHOULD APPLY TO THE ENTIRE BILL
CONSISTENT WITH THE E. U. A
BEFORE NINETY FIVES PROPOSED TO
TRACE EXEMPTION. A BY A
DIFFERING FROM THE E. U. IN
SELECTIVELY ADOPTING ONLY PARTS
OF THE E. U. REGULATION.
INTRODUCES MAJOR QUESTIONS ON
IMPLEMENTATION AND ENFORCEMENT.
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT A
BEFORE NINETY FIVE. NEAR THE E.
U. PERMITTING THE PRESENCE OF
PROHIBITED SUBSTANCES WHICH IS
NOT INTENTIONALLY ADDED.
RESIDENT SMALL CONCENTRATIONS
AND TECHNICALLY UNAVOIDABLE ONE
CONFIRMING ABOUT CONFORMING TO
CURRENT GOOD MANUFACTURING
PRACTICES. AND WE NOTICED ONCE
APPLY TO ALL TRACES AS IT DOES
IN THE E. U. SECTION DE TO
PERMITTING- HE HA TO SET THE
MINIMUS CONCENTRATIONS WOULD NO
LONGER BE NECESSARY. PC PC ALSO
RECOMMENDS HARMONIZING
TERMINOLOGY. IN ORDER TO AVOID
CONFUSION. THE E. U.
REGULATIONS SPEAKS TO PERMITTED
OR PROHIBITED SUBSTANCES.
WHEREAS FOR NINETY FIVE INSTEAD
USES THE LANGUAGE ADULTERATED
WHICH IS A TERM OF ART USED IN
THE US FOOD AND DRUG. AND
COSMETIC ACT. PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COMPANIES WORK WITH AN
EMPLOYEE THOUSANDS OF CHEMISTS
TOXICOLOGISTS BIOLOGIST
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTISTS AND
OTHER EXPERTS TO EVALUATE THE
SAFETY OF THIS COSMETICS. AND
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
INDUSTRY HAS A SHARED INTEREST
WITH CONSUMERS REGULATORS AND
POLICY MAKERS TO PROVIDE SAFE
HIGH QUALITY PRODUCTS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND IS DEDICATED
TO FINDING COLLABORATIVE
SOLUTIONS AND POLICIES GROUNDED
IN SCIENCE AS A BEFORE NINETY
FIVE INTENSE. HOWEVER INTRO A
TRANSPARENT THOUGHTFUL AND
PREDICTABLE PROCESS CAN BE
DESCRIBED WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU OPPOSE AB FOR
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR RAZA
MEASURED. TESTIMONY OF OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR ADAMANTLY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH PC PC AND- OUR POSE BUT
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU. THE
COOKING UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
FIGURES CREATORS ASSOCIATION
TEAM COMMENTS WITHOUT A MANY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN THE
CORRIDOR COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
DON CAP KEEP THANK YOU CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY CESSATION. SEEM TO
AIRLINES FOR THE COMMENTS MADE
LOOKS FORWARD TO FURTHER WORK
THANK YOU. SHARE MEMBERS
CONGESTED WITH AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL OF FOR THE
REASONS STATED THAT APPRECIATE
THE WORK SO FAR THE FOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. DAN CALL OFF WITH
THE- INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
INDEPENDENT COSMETIC
MANUFACTURERS AND DISTRIBUTORS-
WE'LL MINOR COMMENTS WITH- PCP.
AND WOULD LIKE THE AMENDMENTS
MAN THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THEN.
TO THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI BOB SPECIFIC-
COMMENT WAS BROUGHT UP ABOUT-
SEPARATING OUT I BELIEVE IT'S
LEAD IN THIS BEST DOES FROM OUR
E. U. REGULATIONS ARE YOU
WILLING TO MAKE A CHANGE THERE
TO MAKE IT CONSISTENT WITH THE
E. U. I AM FULLY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND YOUR STAFF TO.
ALIGN IT WITH THE EUROPEAN
UNION STANDARDS ARM BUT AS WE
HAVE DISCUSSED YOU KNOW THERE'D
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
FIGURE OUT. IN A SPEECH IN
SITUATIONS WHERE FOUR EGGS WITH
ESPECIALLY IS THAT DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES- IN FORCE TO- THE
STANDARDS IN IN IN DIFFERENT
WAYS AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- ALIGN OURSELVES
BUT AGAIN I THINK THERE. THE
INTENT- AND MY COMMITMENT IS
TO. ALIGN THE STANDARD SO THAT
WHAT. IT IS- IS SOLD IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION CAN BE SOLD
AGAIN CALIFORNIA RIGHT AND
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE- PARTICIPATE IN
THE GLOBAL STANDARD NOW. THE
OTHER QUESTION YOU MENTIONED A
WAREHOUSE SETTING A MINIMUM.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IN FOR
INCORRECT WE CAN DISCUSS THAT
LATER IS THAT DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES DO SET THAT
DIFFERENTLY. ARKHAM SO IT'S
GONNA TAKE SOME RESEARCH TO
FIGURE OUT ARE WE SHOULD COME
UP WITH THAT. AND HOW WE DO TO
FIND IT IF THE E. REALLY DOES
HAVE A UNIFORM. ADEFINITION I
WILL CERTAINLY WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S PUT IN THE
BILL. ARE AS WE BELIEVE AT THE
MOMENT THEY DON'T HAVE A
UNIFORM DEFINITION OF WHAT IT
TO MINIMUS AMOUNT IS- AND IT'S
DONE BY DIFFERENT COUNTRIES AND
WELL TO FIX SOMETHING THAT.
RIGHT NOW THAT'S THE REASON I
HAVE WE ARE INVOLVED FOR
INCORRECT WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT. I WILL ALSO SAY THAT IF
YOU HAVE BETTER WRITE THIS BELL.
TO LET US KNOW AND WE WILL TAKE
A LOOK AT SO THERE MAY BE A
BETTER WAY TO WRITE IT- I WILL
ALSO SAY THAT WE'RE NOT BANNING
CHEMICALS ONE BY ONE THE WHOLE
WITHOUT DOING SCIENCE. THE
WHOLE REASON FOR WITH THE
STANDARD IS. THIS IS
TRADITIONAL INDUSTRY IN EUROPE.
THEY KNOW THIS BETTER THAN WE
DO BETTER THAN THE FTA AND
FRANKLY GREEN CHEMISTRY IS
KINDA CONSTIPATED. AT ANY THAT
JUST CAME OUT BUT. IT REALLY IS
OUR INTENTION TO USE SCIENCE
AND THAT'S WHY I ASKED FOR THE
U. STANDARDS AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS. OUR IN LINE CERTAINLY
WITH THE INTENTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE NOT TO BAN THINGS
ONE BY ONE WITHOUT GOOD
SCIENCE. THE WHOLE THING HERE
IS TO USE THE E. U. STANDARD
AND I THINK THAT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE- I NOW LIKE TO OPEN
THIS UP. A FIRST I JUST WANT TO
SAY I REALLY APPRECIATE. OUR
COMMITTEE. BECAUSE WE GOT ALL
SORTS OF QUESTIONS BEFORE THIS
CAME UP. LAST YEAR WE GOT THEM
AND AS A RESULT OF WHAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER SAID YOU AND I
WERE WILLING TO DELAY THE BAIL.
THE COMMITTEE IS JUST THE CHAIR
COMMITTEE DEPENDS UPON MEMBERS
BRINGING UP THEIR CONCERNS AND
THAT'S WHAT THESE MEMBERS DO.
AND WE'RE A MUCH STRONGER
COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF IT. ALL
RIGHT MADAM VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I. I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE TWO OF YOU
ARE TRYING TO DO AND I THINK IT
IS WARRANTED FOR SURE- I WAS
TALKING WITH MY STAFF EARLIER
ABOUT THE FACT THAT- WOMEN
CLEARLY PARTICIPATE MORE IN THE
COSMETICS INDUSTRY THAN MEN DO
SO WE'RE PUTTING THINGS. ON
THEM EXCEPT MAYBE FOR YOU OUT.
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME I DON'T
KNOW BUT YOU KNOW WE ARE
PUTTING THESE THINGS ON OUR
FACES OUR BODIES ADDED IT ON A
DAILY RATE SOMETIMES TWICE A
DAY. AND SO ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW
SOMEONE SAY WELL IT'S SUCH A
REALLY NOT VERY HARMFUL WELL.
THAT'S TRUE. PER USAGE BUT OVER
TIME. I DON'T KNOW DO WE KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THAT GETS INTO
OUR SYSTEM AND THEN CAUSES A
PROBLEM SO I DON'T DISMISS. ON
THIS SUGGESTION THAT YOU'RE
MAKING HERE TODAY WITH THIS
BILL BUT I DO RECOGNIZE THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION AND
SAYING I DON'T KNOW. THAT WE
NEED TO GO QUITE THIS FAR CAN
WORK AND JUSTICE IN SOME WAYS
IT SEEM TO FIT- OUR NEEDS HERE
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE GOING
TAKE SOME MEASUREMENTS NOT SURE
HOW FAR YOU GOING TO GO WITH
THAT SOUNDS YOUR NEGOTIATIONS.
SO I'M GONNA HOLD OFF TODAY BUT
I DO REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN
GET. A PLATE FOR EVERYBODY IT
TO PORT OF THIS BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW- I CERTAINLY NOT PUTTING A
DISADVANTAGE FOR. SELLING
UNITED STATES IS NOT ONE. HELP
FARM. SO THAT ME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR OUR
NEXT QUESTIONER. MISTER MISTER
ROUTE OBERNOLTE I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANTED TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSION THE YOU AND
I'VE BEEN HAVING ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE BE AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL SO IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE NEW SECTION E.
THAT'S BEING ADDED SAYS AROUND
PHRASE FOR TIME IF ANY COSMETIC
PRODUCT MADE THREE GOOD
MANUFACTURING. IS INTENDED TO
COMPLY WITH THIS PART COULD
CONTAIN CHEMICAL THAT IS NOT
INTENTIONALLY ADDED IN
TECHNICALLY UNAVOIDABLE THE
CHEMICAL SHOULD NOW BECAUSE BUT
TO BE CONSIDERED ADULTERATED
OKAY SO MY QUESTION IS GOOD
MANUFACTURING PROCESSES- THAT'S
NOT. SOMETHING THAT I AM
FAMILIAR WITH IS THAT A TERM OF
ART LISA WE'VE DECIDED TO TAKE.
AS WE GO FORWARD AND JUST SAY
MANUFACTURING PROCESSES SO THAT
WE DON'T OF YOU KNOW. WORKING
MANY YEARS IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
COME UP WITH CONSENSUS WE OFTEN
FOUND THE BEST THING TO DO IS
TO TAKE OUT THE ADJECTIVES. UP
FURTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT SO JUST
JUST TO BE CLEAR SO THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT DELETES THE
WORD GOOD WELL WILL I DON'T
KNOW IS IT IN THE CURRENT
AMENDMENT OR WOULD SOMETHING
WE'RE GOING TO ASK. LATER YEAH
I GOT HAD. THE REASON EIGHT USE
THE WORDS GOOD MANUFACTURING IS
BECAUSE THAT IS WITHIN YOUR
REFLECTION OF- ARTICLE
SEVENTEEN IN THE U. COSMETIC
REGULATION WHICH IS THE ARTICLE
SEVENTEEN IS THE SAFE HARBOR
PROVISION AND THAT RIGHT IN
THAT REGULATION- THE LANGUAGE
IN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
NOT VERBATIM. THE ARTICLE
SEVENTEEN BUT GOOD
MANUFACTURING IS A REFLECTION
OF THE WAY IT'S DRAFTED IN
ARTICLE SEVENTEEN- HOWEVER
BECAUSE DOCTOR QUIRK JUST SAID
THAT'S NOT DEFINING THAT'S
CONFUSING FOR CALIFORNIA LAW-
WERE- MEETING THE WORD GOOD AND
JUST MANUFACTURING PROCESSES
AND IF IT'S NOT PERFECT THE
AUTHOR CAN CONTINUE TO REFINE
HOW THIS PROVISION AS RIGHT. AS
IT'S PAST OF THE CAN. THE WORD
GOOD IS NOT. THANK RIGHT UP I
HAD A QUESTION ABOUT. I GUESS
PROCESS SO YOU KNOW HERE WE ARE
DEFINING A LIST OF THIRTEEN
CHEMICALS THAT WERE SAYING IT
THAT IS FOR SURE WINNER PERCENT
NOT PERMISSIBLE TO HAVE IN
COSMETICS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THEN WE ARE EMPOWERING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO ON THEIR OWN THROUGH
REGULATION IDENTIFY POTENTIALLY
MORE CHEMICALS THAT MIGHT NOT
BE APPROPRIATE SO TO ME THAT
SEEMS LIKE A STRANGE WAY.
SPLITTING THE BABY IT EITHER WE
ARE. EXERCISE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT THESE ARE THE
CHEMICALS THAT THE SCIENCE
SUPPORTS BANNING WAR WE ARE
POINTING TO THE CALIFORNIA PART
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAYING
YOU GUYS THE EXPERT YOU DECIDE
BUT TO DO BOTH AT THE SAME TIME
SEEMS A LITTLE ODD TO ME I
WONDERED IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN
YOUR REASONING ON THAT.
CERTAINLY SO WE HEARD. V.
OPPOSITION THAT. THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR. I WOULD SUPPORT A
GLOBAL STANDARD. AND SO THAT'S
WHY SUPPORT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
STRONG BUTTON IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT PREFERRED. AND
SO. THAT THAT IS- AND THAT IS
MY INTENT AND WITH THE CHAIRED
STRONG SUGGESTION THAT WE BASE
IT ON THE GLOBAL STANDARDOF
THE EUROPEAN UNION STANDARD
ARM. THAT IS WHY FOR EXAMPLE
THAT THAT LANGUAGE AS A- THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT EXPLAINED
IN A WAS BASED ON- THE LANGUAGE
AND- THE EUROPEAN UNION
REGULATE AN ARM. BECAUSE WE ARE
BASED ON THE STATE ENTERED AND
NOT BASE WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
YOU KNOW WITH WHO IN THIS CASE
WERE AGREEING WITH A. WITH THE
REPRESENTED FROM THE PERSONAL
CARE PROP. THAT WE WERE NOT
TAKING A CHEMICAL BY CHEMICAL
APPROACH BUT RATHER WE ARE
BASING THE BAN ON WHAT IS THE
SCIENCE ACCORDING TO THE EUROPE
UNION AND SO A LOT OF THAT SAME
LOGIC YOU KNOW FOR EIGHTY
POTENTIAL FUTURE CHEMICAL. AND
ARMED AND I SPOKE WITH GARCIA
ABOUT THAT MY COMMITMENT TO
THAT- ANY FUTURE CHEMICALS DAD
WOULD BE STRICTLY LIMITED TO
THOSE THAT ARE BANNED BY THE
EUROPEAN UNION BUT AGAIN YOU
KNOW THE SITE AND SPEAKS. UP
APPROACH TO THAT TO THAT WE ARE.
ADOPT SO IT'S NOT UP TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IT'S NOT UP TO THE LEGISLATURE
BUT IT'S UP TO THE- EUROPEAN
UNION. AND RIGHT IN THAT
AMENDMENT- WE'VE TAKEN OUT THE
LANGUAGE WITH A LIST OF
CHEMICALS AND WE'RE JUST SAYING
THAT THEY CAN ADD SOMETHING IF
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS ADDED
IT. BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT THIS
THING FROZEN IN TIME AND HAVE
TO COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY TIME THERE'S A CHANGE IN
THE EUROPEAN UNION BUT HE'S
TAKING AN AMENDMENT WHICH WILL
SAY. THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CONSTRICT LEE ADD ONLY THINGS
WHICH THE EUROPEAN UNION. HAVE
AT. SO AS I SAID. ARE YOU GOOD
ALTHOUGH I WOULD LIKE TO ARE
COMPLETELY TRUSTS WHAT THE U.
DOES AND THINK THAT THAT'S
WHAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR
CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT WE EXIST TO EXERCISE OUR
OWN LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER
THOSE AND FIVE SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF I WOULD PREFER TO
ACTUALLY HAVE THAT COME BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE IN THEIR
ADDITIONAL CHEMICALS- THAT THE
BAND SO I REALIZE THAT THIS IS
ALL A WORK IN PROGRESS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD I'D LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT.
YOU JUST CHECK I FIND RESPONSE
HERE SO ANOTHER. GARCIA WAS TO
OUR TO WORK ON AN AMENDMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A OPEN
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. WHERE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO'D BE HEARD
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC- HEALTH- REGULATORY
PROCESS- YOU KNOW THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WITH TWO WAY AND SO I KNOW THAT
THAT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE LEGISLATURE BUT NOW AT AT
THE VERY LEAST AND IN THE
SPIRIT OF A- OF OPENED GOOD
GOVERNANCE THAT WE WANT TO WORK
ON AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD
PROVIDE FOR A PROCEDURE TO
ALLOW STAKEHOLDERS TO WAYNE
FRIEND TO POTENTIAL. CHEMICALS
TO BE BAD THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER. MR MURATSUCHI
YOU'VE STATED OUT A LOT OF
COMMITMENTS I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THEM IN IN BLACK AND
WHITE WITHIN THE BILL ITSELF-
ARE YOU ALSO PLANNING ANY
SAFEGUARDS IN CASE THE E. U.
CHANGES ITS PROCESS ON WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT- BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THE WAY THEY'RE DOING
THEIR SYSTEM. MY MAKES SENSE
BUT THEY CAN ALWAYS CHANGE HOW
THEY'RE DOING THINGS- SO I
THINK WE NEED TO SAFEGUARD
PROVISION AND THAT- IF THAT'S
THE DIRECTION THAT IT'S GOING
SO IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS IN
ON THE OTHER SIDE IT'S YOU
KNOW. WE'RE WE'RE FOLLOWING THE
E. U. BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT GOING OVER THERE BETWEEN
THE ROYAL FAMILY BREAKING UP
AND EVERYTHING ELSE SO. YOU
NEVER KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO COME OUT WITH NEXT SO I
THINK- MISTRAL REALTY DOES HAVE
A FEW POINTS ABOUT ENSURING
THAT THERE IS A PROVISION WHERE
THINGS CAN COME BACK THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE'S WHILE.
CERTAINLY AND- ACTING. SO AND
SO UNTIL I SEE IT ALL IN
WRITING I'M GONNA HOLD OFF ON
MY VOTE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
WE ALREADY HAVE THE RIGHT. IF
THERE IS A CONCERN. CERTAINLY
YOU COULD BRING UP THE BELL.
SAME WE CAN NO LONGER CONTRAST
THE E. U. AND THAT SO THAT'S
ALREADY OPEN. CURRENT RULES. TO
SHARED THE BILL AND. WELL I'LL
HEAR YOUR BILL I GUARANTEE IT.
OKAY THE OTHER QUESTIONS. IF
THERE ARE NO OTHER QUESTIONS WE
CAN PROBABLY CALL THE ROLL AND
GET THE VOTE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA GUY HAD I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF THE
CHAIRMAN AND THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING. ANA ORDERS LEE. AND
TAKING IN A LOT OF OUR REQUEST
SERIOUSLY ALONG THE WAY AND I
KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT IN A-
FINISH PROCESS AND I APPRECIATE
THE OTHER SEVEN SIXTEEN TO WORK
WITH ALL OF US INCLUDING MY
OFFICE AND- TRIED TO BE ENGAGED
IN. THE CHURCH COME IN TO BRING
THIS BACK AND WE NEED TO AT
SOME POINT WHEN INFANTS
BATHHOUSE SO I JUST WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMITMENTS. I THINK THERE'S A
LITTLE CONFUSION ABOUT. WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON AND SO I WILL HAVE MAYBE I
COULD RESTATE WHAT I THINK THAT
IS. AND THEN ONE MORE ITEM
THOUGH THAT. DESPITE UP BY THE
OPPOSITION AND I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANY RESPONSE FROM. ON THE OTHER
MAYBE HE ONCE BEFORE I LIST
THAT STUFF. TALK ABOUT TH
THEIR CONCERN ABOUT ADULTERATED
VERSUS PROHIBITED IN THAT LINE
AND IF THERE. IS A SENSE THAT
HAPPENED OR IS THERE PURPOSE
FOR THAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT ITEM PLEASE. SO THE
ADULTERATED LANGUAGE COMES FROM
THE SERMON LAW THE EXISTING
LAW. AND SO ON THIS BILL IS.
BUILDING UPON THE EXISTING LAW-
AND IT- IDENTIFIED THESE
THIRTEEN BECAUSE- IT TOXIC
CHEMICALS. TO BE. IN A WAY ANY
RESIDENTS INTENTIONAL INCLUSION
OF THESE THIRTEEN TOXIC
CHEMICALS INTO- A COSMETIC
WOULD BE DEEMED TO BE OUT ALL
TRADED UNDER THE SHERMAN LAW SO
THAT IS WHERE THE TERM
ADULTERATED CONCERT. AND SO
WHAT. WAS YOUR INTENTION ALL
ALONG TO THEN USE ULTRA
ADULTERATED AND MAKE IT OPENS
TO THE CRIMINAL. SIDE OF THINGS.
V. S. SHERMAN LAW ALLOWS FOR
BOTH A CIVIL AS WELL AS A
CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT- BUT YES
THE THAT THIS BILL DOES. OF A
FOR THE SAKE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION- DOES CALL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
REFER ANY VIOLATIONS OF THE
SHERMAN LAW TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. AND FOR YOUR
FRIENDS BECAUSE MEDICS AND IN
OTHER AREAS OF THE SHERMAN LAW
PLANS LIKE THEM JUST NOW
LEARNING ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
ITEMS I APOLOGIZE THAT I'M NINE
THIRTY WE HAD ALREADY HAD A
PRETTY THOROUGH DISCUSSION ON
IT. I DO FEEL LIKE I NEED TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT- THAT.
ARE THEY. THE SIMILARITY APPLY
TO ANYTHING IN THE COSMETICS
INDUSTRY OR IS THIS SOMETHING
YOUR BRAIN INTO THIS INDUSTRY
OR- CAN YOURSELF OR MAYBE
SOMEONE ELSE. WELL. SURE A AS
THE COMEDIAN ELSE'S. CLEARLY
LAYS OUT THE. ON THE BASIC
PILLARS OF- EXISTING LAWS A
RELATES TO COSMETIC REGULATIONS
ARE V. S. S. TO STATE LAWS IS
ONE THE AYE THE SHERMAN LAW-
AND SO- AND THE OTHER BEING THE
SAFER COSMETICS ACT- BUT- IT
THE LEADING LAW AS IT RELATES
TO ADULTERATED COSMETICS IS THE
SHERMAN LAW AND SO. AS.
EXPLAINED AND ON PAGES TO AND
THREE AND FOUR OF FOR THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THIS BILL
IS A IS NOT JUST A WHOLESALE
CREATING NEW LAW BUT IT'S BUT
IT'S- EXPANDING UPON EXISTING
LAW TO STRENGTHEN THE OIL UNDER
EXISTING LAW FOR THE SECOND
CONSUMER PROTECTION. I ADDED-
FOR ANY OF MY MRS WITH NO WAIT
A SECOND. BEFORE WE GET TO
THAT- CRISTINA YOU SATISFIED
WITH THE ANSWER YOU'VE HEARD OR
DO YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS. I HAVE A DIVISIONAL
QUESTIONS. I'M JUST TRYING TO
PROCESS THE THIS WITH THE TH
BUT WITH THAT ACTUALLY MEANS.
AND IN FAIRNESS- I SAW THIS
YOUNG LADY HERE ME CAN SHE-
SELECT YES IT'S OBVIOUS I'M
CERTAIN IF. YOU COULD ASK HER A
QUESTION GO AHEAD. PLEASE GIVE
ME YOUR TAKE NOT AT THE SAME
QUESTION SURE. AND SO THE
SHERMAN LAW AND ALREADY DOES
COVER BECAUSE MEDICS AND IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX- THERE WAS
A LAW PASSED THAT EMPOWERS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS WHEN IT COMES TO
COSMETIC THAT HOT THERE ARE
ADULTERY TO IT'S THAT ARE
DANGEROUS INJURIOUS TO. TO US-
AND SO THIS IS MEANT TO MERIT
THE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS THAT
THE FDA HAS. AN AND- WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING WITH EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY FIVE IS TO AMEND THIS
GERMAN LAW TO CLARIFY THAT. ANY
PRODUCTS INCLUDING THESE
INGREDIENTS THE THIRTEEN
INGREDIENTS WOULD BE.
ADULTERATED UNDER THE LAW SO
AGAIN IT PUTTING AN BILLION
LINE WITH THE USE. OF PROHIBITS
IT INGREDIENTS BUT WE USE. THE
WORD ADULTERY BECAUSE THAT'S
WAS ALREADY IN THE. DOES THAT
MAKES. AND AGAIN- OUR
COMMITMENT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF SOMETHING CAN BE SOLD IN THE
TWENTY EIGHT UNFORTUNATELY SEEM
TO BE TWENTY SEVEN E. U.
COUNTRIES ARE THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO FIGHT IN CALIFORNIA SO
THAT'S THE COMMITMENT AND THE
WE CERTAINLY HAVE SOME DETAILS
TO WORK OUT. BUT I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE NOW TO SEND THE
BILL OUT AND WORK OUT THOSE
DETAILS WITH SOMETHING WHICH IS
SOLID AS A BEEN IN MOTION FOR
THE BILL THE NOT YET. I MAKE
THE MOTION- I THINK THAT I HAVE
A CONCERNS I'M MAKING THE
MOTION BUT I AM IN THE SPREAD
OF THE COLLABORATION THAT WE
HAVE AND THEY AGREEMENT- MAKE
THE MOTION. SO WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT ON THE. ONLY ON. THE
HARBOR AND LOOKING AT THE PIECE
OF LEAD AND. ASBESTOS IN THAT I
AND WHAT EXACTLY THAT LOOKS
LIKE AN HOUR TRANSFER IT OUT
BUT I KNOW THAT'S ONE OF THE
COMMITMENTS WORKING ON- THE
COMMITMENT ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH IN THE PROCESS THAT
CREATES THAT THERE IS A TIME
LINE PUBLIC NOTICES HEARINGS
AND SO FORTH- SO THEY'RE STILL
PROCESS I MAKE A LITTLE FEAR-
AND WHAT EXACTLY THAT LOOKS
LIKE AT THE THEIR SPANISH OUT
THERE BUT I KNOW THAT THAT'S
PART OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT. MOVING FORWARD- AS
WELL AND SO THOSE ARE THE
PIECES- AND HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
TO ME SO I APPRECIATE THAT AND
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE TRYING TO
MAKE THIS CONSISTENT WITH THE
E. WITH THE- CAL MODEL THANKS
TO BE ME ARM AND SO IT BUT
CONSISTENT IN THERE AND SO I
DO. APPRECIATE THAT COMMITMENT
TO THE ABSOLUTELY- AND- SO I AT
I WILL BE WAITING FOR. AND THEN.
FONT BACK IN THOSE PIECES
HOPEFULLY WE GET THAT I WHAT'S
RIGHT SOONER THAN LATER. OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION DO WE HAVE A
SECOND AND THEN FROM DOCTOR
ARAMBULA. UGH MR HOLDEN SECONDS
DOCTOR ARAMBULA THANK YOU AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NEEDING TO BE IN
TWO PLACES AT ONCE AND MISSING.
PART OF YOUR TESTIMONY- BUT I
DO WANT TO APPRECIATE BOTH THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING AS WELL
AS THE CHAIR TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION FORWARD- MISSILES
STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT ONLY
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE IT IN
PRINT. AND I DON'T MEAN TO. BE
DISMISSIVE OF THE COMMITMENT
BUT JUST WANTING TO ENSURE THAT
WE DO MEET THAT EASY YOU
STANDARD. AND THAT THE- FINAL
PRODUCT IS THERE- TODAY I'M
GOING TO RESERVE MY RIGHT TO
VOTE. UNTIL I CAN SEE IT WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOUR OFFICE AND SEE IF BY THE
TIME IT REACHES THE FLOOR I CAN
SUPPORTED AND- HELPED ACROSS I
JUST- UNTIL I. KNOW EXACTLY
THAT IT'S ALIGNED I BELIEVE AND
IT TO RESERVE THAT RIGHT AND SO
JUST WANT TO COMMUNICATE THAT
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE.
TO WORK ON IT UNTIL IT'S- IN
ITS- ACT. ALL RIGHT ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU AGAIN.
I THINK I'VE MADE MY COMMITMENT
CLEAR- THE SPIRIT OF MY
COMMITMENT IS CLEAR AND- WITH
THAT I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
CONVERSATIONS- MIGHT LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
BILL FOR THE CONVERSATION
FORWARD I ASK FOR YOUR LIFE.
RIGHT AND AGAIN- MY PLEDGES
WELL AND MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
AB FOR NINETY FIVE MORE A TO
CHEAT THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
MELENDEZ WHY DOES NOT VOTING
-ARAMBULA. NUMBER ARE NOT
VOTING POWER QUE HAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE MATHIS. WHAT A TO G. HI RED
TO GI OBERNOLTE. TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE WE DO HAVE FIVE BOATS THAT
ONE IS OUT WILL HOLD THE. THE
BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
IT'S ALL AND- WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK- I WILL GIVE FIVE
MINUTES OF FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS TO RETURN OTHERWISE
SELF. BE RECORDED IS NOT VOTING
WHICH IS I HAVE A FEELING WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO ANYWAY. THANK
YOU. YEAH IT'LL BE BY MY WATCH
IT'S TWO TWENTY THREE WILL DO
IT WILL STAY TOLD TO TWENTY
EIGHT BY MY WATCH. ONE YEAH
RIGHT
. YEAH
. YEAH. YEAH
. OKAY
YEAH
. HIGH DEFINITION. YEAH
YEAH. YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH.
YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH RIGHT
YEAH BUT I. YEAH. YEAH BUT.
YEAH. OKAY
. IT'S TWO TWENTY
EIGHT- MISTER MATHIS AND MISTER
OBERNOLTE WOULD BE PUT DOWN IS
NOT VOTING AND THE BILL PASSED
AND SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
CALL THIS YEAR INTO AN AND